all right i want to sort of get ahead of
this story and spend some time today
talking about supposed biden mask
mandates because the amount of
disinformation that we're already seeing
if it's at all a preview is going to
absolutely explode when joe biden is
actually
sworn in as president of the united
states on january 20th
so to go back a little bit right wingers
have been warning even during the
campaign
joe biden will lock everyone in their
homes joe biden will be a dictator with
masks and all sorts of other things if
he becomes president
and over the last 48 to 72 hours we
heard two different things that are not
the same thing very important
we heard from dr anthony fauci that
indeed joe biden plans to do
a hundred day mask initiative and
within that there will be a piece that
is a federal mass mandate now when you
hear federal mass mandate many people
imagine something that is very different
from what we're actually going to get so
let me say this in the clearest
terms possible joe biden nor
any president can mandate
a national mask wearing law
where everybody's forced to wear a mask
outside of their homes i've already
addressed this so listen
very closely to what i'm going to say
what joe biden can do
is address the nation from the oval
office and
ask people to wear masks he can
call the governors of 50 states and
ask them to put in place mass mandates
which governors can do
in various areas massachusetts governor
charlie baker is an example earlier this
week he's a republican announced that
there will be a mass mandate in
workplaces in massachusetts
we got an email from our office tenant
where
everybody's working from home anyway
right now but they said everybody's got
to wear a mask per
charlie baker's order governors can do
that given states rights
and yet there's a ton of headlines today
which are very confusing in talking
about a joe biden
nationwide mask mandate suggesting
the federal government will force
everybody to wear a mask so let me
explain what's going on
as the president of the united states
part of the
a federal government joe biden plans to
issue
a mask mandate that includes federal
buildings
as well as airplanes trains and buses
which are regulated by the
federal department of transportation
that's it
that's the mandate that's what the
president can do via executive order and
in just about every state masks are
already required in all of those places
now i do have
some federal government employee friends
who work in red states who have told me
you know
the the equivalent agency in
massachusetts and in california
you've got to wear a mask in my office
for that same agency in a red state our
boss has not mandated masks
that will change based on this mask
mandate for federal buildings
but it will change very little else so
before we go crazy misstating what this
is joe biden's mandate will apply only
to federal buildings
and transportation vehicles regulated by
the dot
beyond that any mass guidelines from
biden will merely be guidelines they
will be
requests they will be proposals uh it
will be up to your governor to decide
what to do that's it
now dr fauci has said wearing masks for
a hundred days is a good idea
it will be up to the people and
governors ultimately to decide what it
is they want to do
for people who have been wearing masks
for months already
this is going to be much ado about
nothing consider that you know there is
now a light at the end of the tunnel
let's actually work together to start
getting past this if we can start here's
my trajectory
if we can start vaccinating five to
seven percent of our population each
month
maybe that includes december maybe we
only get
you know one two percent done in
december in january we get five to seven
percent
february et cetera this means in six
months we could have somewhere between
30 and 42
of the population vaccinated plus the
five to ten percent who will have
recovered from the virus
we don't yet know how uniform
immunity is when you recover there's the
idea
that if you have a very light case your
immunity may not be as robust as if you
recover from a more serious case so we
don't know exactly
but we could be heading towards a
roughly 50 level of immunity by may 1st
maybe by may 15th
that won't be the end but it will be a
dramatically better situation
we will also likely at that point have
cheap at-home tests
so like for me if i imagine hey i might
be able to order
50 or 100 of these cheap at home rapid
tests
i've been very cautious but i've
continued going to the grocery store
i go to the post office during the
summer i was hanging out
outdoors with friends eating outdoors at
restaurants
if we had on may 15th may 1st may 15th
50 immunity and these at home tests i
would likely be ready to say for example
hey here's a group of six friends
we've all been working from home if we
all do a rapid test
i would be comfortable if we're all
negative hanging out indoors maintaining
a reasonable amount of distance
uh assuming we're at 50 immunity with
these tests
okay i mean listen it's it's it's not
perfect
but we're talking about may june and to
be clear with half the country
vaccinated now you also have to remember
there is a lag time on vaccination
immunity
and what i mean by that is the time
until vaccinated people actually reduce
the number of deaths
could is weeks and what i mean by that
is on day one you get dose number one
dose number one confers some immunity
but not all so
that starts to have an effect day 22
21 days later you get your second dose
and then seven days after that
you would be considered to be night you
know there's a 95 chance that you were
immune so
by day 28 to 29
you ideally are no longer
getting other people sick who you might
have gotten sick were you not vaccinated
since it takes 20 days in general from
when someone
catches the virus to when they die if
they're going to die
vaccinated individuals will not be
fully effective at reducing deaths
for 48 days we won't see the impact on
deaths of a vaccinated individual
for up to 48 days now we know that after
dose one you can be as much as 70 or
even 75
percent likely uh to be immune so these
are all
confidence intervals but i think you
understand the point that there's a lag
time um before which
vaccination uh is not really doing doing
that much
to stop cases and to stop death so the
the point is this is a process
and it there is every indication that by
may 1 may 15
we will be in a better situation masks
will likely be required in just as many
places as they are today
uh but we are now we had 2 960 people
die yesterday were
essentially at a 9 11 every day so
rather than
the point is rather than lying about
what joe biden plans to do
let's work together and start getting
past this